organizer
okay so hi my name is Adam Smith I'm
happy to be here I'll be talking about
differentially private algorithms for
analyzing network structure and
specifically under a strong guarantee
called a node node level differential
privacy okay so of course graph datasets
come up everywhere and and especially in
in the context of sensitive privacy
where you know we're often looking at
datasets where nodes correspond to
people and edges correspond to
relationships between people and these
things are of course potentially very
sensitive they can capture they could
might represent social or romantic
relationships they might represent
friendships in an online social network
maybe financial transactions phone calls
all sorts of things you know
doctor-patient relationships so lots of
different kinds of graphs where the
nodes are people edges are committed or
connections between people and we want
to analyze these networks and learn
things about them without revealing too
much about individuals so this is really
the quest central question that drove
this line of research what information
can we release about these types of
networks Oh subject to strong guarantees
of privacy and I won't go through it
here but there are lots of examples of D
anonymization attack you know sort of
naive failures of naive attempts to do
this right you can sort of try to
anonymize networks in various ways and
by and large they don't work very well
against attackers who have even modest
site information about the network so
we'll be looking at algorithms for which
we can make provable statements and of
course you know we've given my own
interests that I focused on differential
privacy so broadly we'll say two data
sets or neighbors if they differ in one
individuals data and an algorithm is
differentially private if it's out
roughly the same if its distribution on
outputs is roughly the same for all
pairs of neighbors now what it means
that two data sets are neighbors start
is a subtle and interesting question
when our data consists of some sort of
network information okay so there are at
least two very natural variants one is
called edge differential privacy where
I'll say two graphs our neighbors if
they differ in one edge and then a
differentially private algorithm would
hit hide the presence or absence of a
particular relationship in the network
okay or the the removal of a particular
relationship from the network or its
addition a stronger notion that's harder
to achieve though is called no
differential privacy so we'll say two
graphs our neighbors and in this notion
if one can be obtained from the other by
deleting a node and all of its adjacent
edges or alternatively by inserting a
new node and an arbitrary set of new
edges
so under either you get you differential
privacy sort of mathematically make
sense under either of these notions
we'll say the algorithm is
differentially private if for you know
any two graphs that are neighboring
under the irrelevant notion the
probability of any particular output is
about the same under these two you know
under these two graph these two inputs
okay but really today I'm gonna be
focusing on so there's lots of work on
edge differential privacy and some of it
I've done I'm not going to talk about
that at all today so I won't even try to
survey it because there's a lot of it
there's less work on no differential
privacy and I'll talk more about that
and that's gonna be the focus of today's
my talk so in order to sort of
understand what you know why node
privacy is interesting and challenging
it helps to just play with a specific
example and somehow my animation got
screwed up but sorry so one of the
things that made makes no challenge no
privacy challenging is that they're
they're the under this notion of
neighbor of adjacency that lots of the
things we want to compute have very high
sensitivity can't recall the global
sensitivity of a function is the maximum
difference you can see in that function
when you consider two neighboring data
sets so in this case graphs for whom
where a person has been added to the
network and now we're gonna look at yeah
we're gonna look at this notion of
sensitivity but under the addition of a
node and an arbitrary set of edges to
the network so for example we might look
at the simple statistic might be the
number of edges in the graph or perhaps
something a little more interesting may
be the number of triangles in the graph
for example and the problem is that
these for for if I look at a graph on n
no
then this this the sensitivity of the
number of edges in the graph is very
high under this notion of adjacency
right if I add one person to the graph
with all possible edges then I might
have increased the number of edges in
the graph by n or n minus 1 depending
exactly I don't how you define things
and if I consider like the number of
triangles in the graph then the
sensitivity could be even larger it
could be as large as well
sorry everything's getting this up as
large as n choose 2 ok and I and this
problem doesn't we can't really solve
this problem by considering say local
sensitivity because even under local
sensitivity most graphs I mean all
graphs are close to our neighbors of
some other graph with a very different
number of edges so these are both global
sensitivities and they are also
essentially local sensitivities the
first one is always the local
sensitivity the second one it depends on
the structure the network but it's
always it's it's generally high so local
so just looking at local sensitivity
somehow like not enough we need to
change our tool set further ok and
hopefully from now on the animations
will be a little more rational so so
there's sort of a broad you know
approach to doing this is to somehow
restrict the class of graphs we consider
and and somehow work with a restricted
class of graphs so for example let's
consider is this is a very simple
example and we'll see more complex ones
later in the talk but what happens if I
just restrict my attention to grip to
those graphs where the maximum degree is
bounded above by some known quantity
deep ok so it turns out that I I mean I
could I can define a notion of global
sensitivity for this subset of inputs ok
or sort of the sensitivity restricted to
this subset of inputs and a nice
observation is that for lots of useful
functions this this restricted
sensitivity the Lipchitz constant of
when you restrict your attention to this
subclass of inputs is in fact not so
high so for example if I look at the
number of edges then the look the the
global sensitivity restricted to graphs
of degree at most D is now D instead of
n for triangles it would be d choose two
and so if we somehow had you know if we
if we could somehow get a promise that
our our input lay in this kind of nice
class of graphs then we could design
much more accurate differentially
private algorithms by for example in
this case adding noise proportional to
this restricted notion of sensitivity
now this observation doesn't solve our
problem because first of all we don't
know what our graph looks like without
actually looking at it and what we'd
like is a privacy guarantee that holds
for all possible inputs not only that
not only the inputs we hope we have but
you know the ones we actually get right
nevertheless this this sort of approach
is is a like a key component of the most
almost all the work on node privacy that
in some sense you want to project on to
some like nice family of graphs not
always this panel so the in fact it sort
of leads to this general technique that
was first developed and and
interestingly appeared in three
concurrent papers in 2013 by Chen and Jo
Blum blocky da
and chef ed and and Keshava chuan have
done this English let me come in myself
so you the sort of broad approaches
you're gonna identify some nice set of
graphs for example you know those graphs
with bound to degree hopefully this
includes the graphs you think you care
about right then you design an algorithm
that's differentially private on these
nice inputs and then somehow you fix or
extend this algorithm so it it is
private on all possible inputs
and exactly how you do steps two and
three and while all three of these steps
varies from to some extent from paper to
paper all those there's some common
elements okay so these three papers
looked at applying this to a subgraph
counting statistics how many edges how
many triangles how many different
patterns of a given type might you see
there was some subsequent work that
looked at degree distributions and then
another pair of papers that I was
involved in that looked at fittings or
fairly complex to network models from
statistical models to graphs and that's
what I'm going to talk about more today
mostly today and I'll just mention
there's a sort of separate aspect to a
lot of these papers which is how do you
choose this nice set of graphs in a way
that actually depends on the data you
have rather than just sort of going in
with your eyes closed and hoping and
that this there's again there's sort of
like a few different ways you might do
that this will come up I guess
implicitly in this talked of view and
tall wire that we'll see I think on
Thursday history
okay so what I'd like to do for the sort
of the bulk of the talk is to tell you
to tell you a bit about how this is sort
of philosophy and this approach plays
out in the context of a specific problem
that is of fitting what are called
stochastic block models to network data
and I will now change slides because my
co-authors are Beamer people
[Music]
alright so in this parent papers we we
consider a specific family of network
models that I'll define in a minute and
we look we give new algorithms and also
lower bounds and impossibility results
on how well we can estimate the
parameters of these models under no
differential privacy okay and so in many
men we look at stochastic estimating
stochastic block models in the many
regimes we give an optimal we give an
algorithm that matches the non private
the best non from the optimal non
private algorithm and we also give some
lower bounds showing that you you know
when you can't match the non private
algorithm that sometimes that that cost
of privacy is not unfortunately
necessary and we also give some
interesting sort of special case results
for the very special case a narrow case
of what are called an erdos-renyi graph
so these are this is like a the simplest
state generative stochastic Network
model where all edges appear
independently with a given probability P
and you just want to estimate P and we
give roughly tightly the optimal
estimation rate they're using sort of
some some new tools that I'll try to
explain so you know briefly outlined for
the rest of the talk I told you a little
bit about node level privacy and some of
the challenges that come up I'll try to
explain what stochastic block models are
and why we might care about them and
then I'll try to summarize what we know
about these models both sort of in terms
of what we can achieve and what
impossibility results we can provide and
as I said I'll spend a bit of time on
the case the very special cake the term
one what's called the one block case the
erdos-renyi model and say tell it tell
you a little bit about that and if I get
time all I'll sort of tell you about
some fairly general tool that came out
in this in these works that I think is
broadly applicable so what's the
stochastic block block model so it's a
generative model for a graph it's
specified by a number n and another
number K so n is going to be the number
of nodes in the graph and K is going to
be a number of types of notes so they're
going to be K kinds of nodes in the
graph okay so we have and then one other
matrix which specifies how likely it is
that edge that nodes of two given types
are to be connected that sentence didn't
work but I'll explain again all right so
here's the process that comes with these
so I'm given n I'm given K and this
matrix is K by K symmetric matrix of
probabilities so in the beginning each
note node choose its it chooses a type
independently of all other nodes and for
simplicity we'll imagine that the types
are uniformly distributed they don't
have to be it can be any distribution on
types and then the two every two nodes
will independently decide to create or
not create an edge with probability
given by the relevant entry of this
connection matrix so for example if I
have n 12 nodes then they might each
choose these there I'll choose they'll
choose their four colors so here are the
four colors and now you know with
probability according to which they look
up in this matrix they create an edge
between so sort of a simple but actually
fairly expressive model of how networks
might arise where there's sort of some
underlying characteristic for each
vertex and the chances that you know
Kobe and I share an edge are dictated by
art by these characteristics for example
you know where we work what we work our
area of science personality types
whatever it is
and so this the the complexity of the
model is controlled by this parameter K
which sort of how many different types
of people you've imagined there are in
the world and a you and it makes sense
even to choose K very very large it lets
make sense to let K go to infinity but
then how well you can estimate the
resulting object of course will degrade
the more degrees of freedom you a lot of
the model okay
in the special case that K equals one
then everybody is the same type and then
the probability that any two nodes are
connected is the same and independent of
all other nodes again and so that that's
what's called the air - Renia model
that's a widely studied generative model
must have you probably seen it or
another okay so here's our this is our
our stochastic model I'll use the
shorthand G and B to describe a random
graph selected according to that model
so B is the matrix of parameters but
sometimes we'll need sparsity and we'll
import and post par so that the sparsity
so that the restriction the the rows
sparsity restriction is just a
restriction that all the probabilities
in this matrix lie between 0 and Rho
okay so one way to capture sparse models
in this sparse networks and this type of
model is to let Rho go down as n goes to
infinity if you think about it that way
so the larger n is the smaller Rho might
be and that allows you to conserve
capture essentially arbitrary
relationships between the size of the
network and the number of the density of
the network company the fraction of
edges that are actually present ok those
these stochastic block block models are
very widely studied at least for that
privacy concern considerations so there
are some nice connections with community
detection detection problems in
complexity they're very planted
bisection problems and planted clique
problems that can be that can be sort of
encapsulated by these stochastic block
models they come up in statistical
philip physics
if you've ever heard of semi ratings
regularity lemma there's a sense in
which it is talking about how well
arbitrary graphs can be approximated by
these types of models so that there's
lots of nice work on on these models and
how they relate to the like rest of the
mathematical universe and and just one
note since I had I mentioned the word
graph on earlier graph ons are roughly
what you get when you take this model
and let K go to infinity so you can have
like infinitely many types every node
can be its own type and then you get
meaningful models by sort of restricting
this connection probability matrix to be
like not too complicated but I'm just
gonna talk about finite K for today yeah
yeah essentially what we're gonna do is
we're going to look at how I'm going to
talk about convergence rates so and
imagine ends going to infinity and K
will also be allowed to grow within and
I'm not going to constrain the
relationship all right so what's the
statistical problem we're going to
consider we're got we've got a given one
graph from this model we'd like to
estimate the matrix of connection
probabilities using an algorithm that is
itself constrained to be differentially
private in the strong sense of being no
differentially private so even just to
formulate this problem is to forget
privacy to formulate what we mean by
estimating B correctly is a little
tricky and that's because I sort of I
don't know that the the types don't
really have names right I it's not that
I there are these K types but if I'm
given gee I don't know even if I could
identify which vertices are of the same
type ice cream I don't know if that's
type 1 or type 3 like there's no kind of
necessarily clear relationship by it
because it's not like I know B that's
what I'm trying to figure out so what
we'll do
we'll say the this algorithm that's
estimating is going to output some
matrix of connection probabilities it's
going to hope that it's close to B but
because it doesn't know the labeling of
the K different types will allow it to
find a matrix which is closed under any
labeling so we'll define the error in
estimation of B by the output of a to be
the minimum over permutations of the K
labels of the sort of the closeness of
the permuting matrix to be okay so we're
essentially we're gonna mod out by all
permutations of the label names or
alternatively just consider two matrices
equivalent if they are if they differ
only in a permutation of the rows and
columns no there's no assumption and
it's just symmetric so positive
definiteness doesn't have a I mean not
necessarily no but both makes sense it
makes sense sometimes to have you know
people at the same time more likely to
connect but depending on the kind of
edge the relationship you're modeling
that may not make sense that's not baked
in the month yeah sorry this is just I
that's a good question I cuz I didn't
explain this is just like the it's the
Frobenius norm if you want it's just
that like I'm gonna write think of the
matrix as a big list and look at the
Euclidean distance between the two back
resulting vectors and you you could put
any other metric sort of reasonable
metric here and derive similar results
exact form would change yeah each block
is not part of output
no and that there there are a few
reasons for that
so first differentiating privately you
couldn't know differentially privately
you couldn't hope to do that because
you'd be like naming people but also
there are even non privately there
lots of interesting settings where
you've got enough information to
estimate be well but not to estimate
which nodes are of which type well which
is sort of surprising turns out those
are like not not the same problem okay
so sorry so means we're gonna look at
just mean squared error which is the
expected you know given a model B and an
estimator a the mean squared error is
the expected Delta to distance squared
between the output of the algorithm and
the true model there's some worst-case
perform will look at minimax bands so
we'll look at the worst case overall be
that our row sparse and K by K that's
going to be our metric of how well the
algorithm does and what we're really
interested in is sort of what is the
performance of the best output so that's
the thing that the quantity we're trying
to nail down notice that these two
measures here as I formulated them they
kind of assume that the true graph is it
was generated from a model of the same
type that you're trying to estimate
right there's that there's a nice match
between the kind of generative form of
the real of nature and the real of the
model you're trying to use which and
generally don't expect that I'm going to
stick with that for the talk but in the
paper we talk about a more general
setting where we don't sort of constrain
the model from which the graph was
generated
okay so let me tell you what what we do
know about these models and and also
what we don't so roughly speaking what
we show in sort of they're a pair of
papers with the first paper which
Christian Borges and Jennifer chains
from MSR and the second paper with those
two plus alia Sadiq this is a student at
MIT who will be going to NYU next year
as a postdoc and they so what we show
and the the stronger of the two results
the second result is the following bound
on the estimation right okay it is you
can admire it it's got a lot of terms so
let me sort of break it down at least a
little bit so it's easier to think about
so let's get some intuition for what
going on first of all I think for all
intents and purposes you can ignore roe
and in in red-suited a sort of occurred
to me as I was preparing the talk that I
should just remove roe entirely from the
talk but then I was afraid that I would
introduce like crazy inconsistency so
just ignore bro or pretend it's one
we've got a few different terms here
that the these terms don't involve that
epsilon and these ones do the terms that
don't involve epsilon there are two of
them and they sort of naturally come up
there's a term that's K squared over N
squared and that is it turns out like
the mean squared error you would get if
I told you all the types of the vertices
and you just had to figure out with no
privacy constraints what the parameters
of the matrix or how well you know try
and get as as accurate an estimate as
you could of each of the entries of this
connection matrix that's the term you
would get on the other hand if I told
you B and I asked you to try to figure
out where the vertices lie then roughly
speaking you would get this second term
that's like not as clear why how that
comes up but you know one sort of not
entirely honest explanation is to say
that there are sort of K to the N ways
of assigning types to
types to vertices and you you get some
dependence on the log of that many types
oh that's like how much information you
need just to figure out what that
assignment is as I said that's not
really an honest explanation of what's
going on but we'll take it
ok so so that's where these terms come
from and then we'll talk more about
these terms in a minute
the we will use it we used to developed
an algorithm it's not efficient in this
original paper and then the analysis I'm
presenting here it came later ok so one
thing we can say is that the left-hand
terms they have to be there because that
is actually the optimal non-private rate
so that was worked out over a number of
papers but the full statement and some
papers that like including a paper
though Audra and I wrote together but
the full statement came in this paper of
clocks about coffin for sailin and they
so so they showed that this is the the
tight upper and lower bound for
estimating things with no privacy
constraints so our bound is sort of that
plus some other stuff which is the form
you'd expect you know and in a number of
regimes this first term dominates the
second term and so then you get sort of
privacy you know for free at least
asymptotically you get the estimation
error dominates the distortion you
introduced for privacy okay
so I'll explain more about these other
where these other terms come from as we
go but they're they are basically coming
from different parts of the algorithm
itself sir in row a is one
you just said that the second term is
smaller the first two it's that's only
true when roads yeah it's all it's a so
Rho is a density parameter so it tells
you roughly the expected density in the
graph and it's a in this context
secularly it's an upper bound on the
connection probabilities so yeah it took
to Matt for things to match up nicely
you need Rho to not be 1/2
okay so the the the basic idea of the
upper bound the algorithm is is somewhat
is reasonably natural so the first thing
we do is to to measure get a rough idea
of how many edges there are in the graph
so it turns out this is like not super
easy to do but we don't need a very good
idea of how many edges there are in the
graph and so we just use the Laplace
mechanism calibrated the global
sensitivity of the number of edges it
turns out that's good enough for our
purposes it introduces no mean squared
error about 1 over epsilon squared N
squared it's actually like without the
square it would be 1 over epsilon N and
then given that sort of per at that
estimate of the parameters that allows
us to constrain things we runs it's an
inefficient algorithm on Fortran and
it's an open question to come up with a
more efficient version even none none
privately but what we're gonna do is use
the exponential mechanism and a nutshell
to try and select the model that fits
the data as best as possible but using
this density estimate to constrain the
sensitivity of the scores that come up
in the exponential making to a first
approximation what we'll do is we'll
take the score of a given model B hat in
the exponential mechanism to be the
Delta - actually there should be a
square here the the squared error in of
B hat in estimating the graph G and I
realize I don't have the explanation on
the slide of what that means so let me
explain that so we're looking at the
difference between this little K by K
matrix which is a given candidate model
and a big graph represented by its
adjacency matrix so that's you know got
lots of rows and columns so what does it
mean to look at the distance between
these well what we're going to do is
just take the minimum over maps from n
to K of a sort of blown up version of B
hat ok so we're going to take the
minimum over assignments of of types two
edges of the Frobenius distance between
the the blown up version of B hat and
what but what I mean by that is we'll
take like a big you know it's now a big
matrix so G is unchanged and now but
then the the way you find the entries of
this blown up version of B hat is that
you'll you'll you'll use PI to tell you
you know for I and J you're gonna look
at B sub pi of I so you're looking at
the the sort of best assignment of types
for this graph of
using the the proposed edge connection
probabilities in behalf and it and then
you square that which is not I'm not
gonna write it on the board but that
there should be squared and it turns out
even that's not exactly the score we use
we have to make some other changes to it
[Music]
what does it mean well so their
probabilities but they're they're
numbers between 0 & 1 the entries of the
adjacency matrix are also numbers
between 0 & 1
and so we're just going to look at the
Frobenius distance between so it's not
it's not gonna be very low it's gonna be
pretty big right but that's okay I just
need it to be better for the right model
than it is for the wrong models right
and actually there's some additional
stuff we have to do we have to modify
this thing to make it lower sensitivity
one of the modifications is sort of
relatively easy to explain we'll use the
density estimate from the first step to
constrain the global sensitivity of the
score functions using sort of what's
called a Lipschitz extension it's just
some extension of the function from
those graphs with the right density to
all possible graphs and then we would
there some other stuff that's not so
much not maybe not so interesting just
some rewriting of this expression too
and you can throw out some some high
density sensitivity terms that don't
matter
all right so what makes ant so this is
the structure of the algorithm and what
makes it what makes the analogy is that
analyzing how this exhaustive search
algorithm works with noisy scores is non
true well algorithms with perfect scores
which is what KTV did is not so easy and
modifying that analysis to take into
account the extra noise is also not so
easy and in fact we tried the first time
Jennifer Christian and I tried once and
didn't do it very well and then Ilyas
came along and came up with a really
nice argument that improved the analysis
yeah it's not clear you have to but it's
easier at least to run it in a finite
amount of time yes
okay so I'm not going to go through the
the net analysis that that make the net
argument that makes this work because I
didn't know how to do it nicely in a
sort of shorter talk but I'll tell you a
little bit about optimality and some of
the things that come up and and because
they're a little easier to understand
and I think more maybe more insightful
yeah equation why do you need the
Lipschitz extension to the score yes sir
that oh what will be the worst case to
change that I know the good cause that
would be so devastating to this board
well so yeah so this actually mostly
comes up when you're in the sort of
lower density cases and there you can
basically if if this make if the
adjacency matrix is relatively sparse
then adding one vertex that's connected
it to everybody will just screw
everything up
I mean what do you consider sparse cuz
usually the noise that you should get
having the very first one introduces
leaner you know your company the number
that you look to thing your arrow so
this is what do you call sparsely name
your number of edges or yeah so and so
true yeah a good question so um think of
it as at least logarithmic average
degree and to get good results you need
it a little higher for at least four
large it depends on K so so there's sort
of this relationship between K and n and
Rho in both sides that is not so sort of
crisp to explain so I yeah I'll be
honest I I didn't sort of focus on the
case of very low row in the paper we try
to work everything out as clearly as we
can but for the talk I'm sort of not
really pushing the row as low as it can
go
okay so the question that I'll spend the
remaining time I have on which is not
that much is what what can we say about
these other terms so one thing we can
say is that this term appear is is
really necessary okay so we argue that
you can't really get away without this
type of dependency on on n an epsilon
and this term basically comes from that
initial step where we estimate the
density and I have an argument on the
slides I'll mostly skip it's just that
there's some relatively simple family of
two-block models where you can argue you
really need this term okay just to
estimate the number of nodes roughly
speaking the number of nodes of each
type we don't know if this term is
necessary this term comes out of the
exponential mechanism and in fact I said
I would imagine that using under epsilon
Delta differential privacy you can get
get rid of the square I suspect that is
the right dependent that's optimal but I
don't know proof that
so I'm gonna just skip over the lower
band for K equals 2 because it's it's a
reduction to binomial estimation it's
really simple and talk about this the
case of K equals 1 because I think it's
an interesting sort of weirdness that
sorry
let me explain so what we argue is that
in the case when K equals 2 we need this
term to be there the 1 over N squared N
squared is necessary and one might
conjecture that that's even necessary
for K equals 1 just estimate the density
of the graph of a - shreddy graph but
surprisingly the answer is it's not
necessary if K equals 1 we can actually
get like a big improvement in the
estimation rate and I'd like to I'll
spend what time I have left explaining
that so here's a very simple open
problem given a sample from a graph GNP
so let's say n is known but P is not we
want to estimate P it's a simple problem
not privately the thing to do is you
look at the number of edges in the graph
you divide by n choose 2 that's your
estimate that's as good as it gets under
edge differential privacy also it's a
binomial estimation problem you've just
like all edges are equally likely to be
there or not simple under no
differential privacy it's more subtle
because the privacy constraint means
that I can't just treat this as n choose
two independent samples from a binomial
because they're kind of tied together by
the fact but that they're attached to
specific vertices
so our the test for capables Wan is to
you know come up with the estimation
rate for the other Shore any model okay
so the natural thing to do is what I
mentioned earlier just to add Laplace
noise calibrate it to either the global
sensitivity or or maybe some degree
constrained version of it if you know
the degree in your network is not so big
maybe you can do a little better using
the techniques from these previous
papers that I mentioned
it turns out even that's not good enough
and I won't go into why the second
statement but I'll explain why just the
basic thing doesn't work so or doesn't
work as well so that the basic Laplace
mechanism will give you this rate 1 over
N squared that's the underlying that's
the basic estimation rate non privately
just the fact that you have n choose 2
you know samples as n choose 2 edges to
get information from and then this extra
term is the the noise it comes from the
noise you add using the Laplace
mechanism
and so the and this one over N squared
you can't you can't avoid so really the
question is which what term goes there
what's the epsilon dependent part so let
me see if I can I'll skip over the
explanation of why they'll apply what
the Laplace mechanism does but I'll just
explain where try to explain where it
does something weird so the sense tip
that you know the Laplace mechanism we
calibrate the nose noise for the global
sensitivity the global sensitivity is
obtained by considering two graphs that
differ in one vertex that goes from
having no edges at all or almost no
edges at all to lots and lots of edges
okay so I like I maybe I add a vertex
that has that's connected to every one
okay so that's how I get the the global
sensitivity and the local sensitivity as
we mentioned earlier but actually sort
of what we realize playing with it is
that when you when you're dealing with a
graph that's sampled according to GNP
you don't actually expect to ever see a
vertex with very high degree nor do you
ever expect to see a vertex is very low
degree in fact you expect all the
vertices to have almost the same degree
and so what I what we know is that if so
if we are considering two vertices to
two graphs that neighbor that differ in
the in one in the connections of this
one vertex V then even if they even if
that those edges get rewired completely
if the if the total number of edges
changes drastically then I kind of know
I'm not dealing with a graph from the
right model and so I can sort of ignore
the other graph the gret the
weird-looking graph okay so if I get a
big change then one either G or G prime
is going to be sort of atypical for my
model so instead what we'll do is
constrain our restrict our attentions
those graphs that are typical and this
the the sort of superficial notion of
typicality is is going to be that all
the degrees have to be where they're
expected to be and then what we'll see
that it turns out that's not quite
enough and I'll explain it in a second
why that is but but that's going to be
the basic basic idea so the idea so we
want to eight to get an out on the moors
for typical graphs but is private for
all pairs of graphs so the idea is we're
going to construct a good typical set
and good means that it should arise with
high probability under under this model
so for any P the probability that G lies
in my typical set should be high or the
probability it falls outside of it
should be low and somehow the
sensitivity
should be small meaning the global
sensitivity should be small so for all
pairs G & G Prime the change between the
the number of edges in G and the number
of edges in G prime should be about this
quantity square square to log n you can
ignore 1 over N to the three-halves
times the number of vertices that we
rewire to get from G to G Prime and
that's going to be like the the sorry
squared of n and well yeah we're
dividing by n squared so squared of n
times the number of vertices that were
rewired and that's going to be the key
step and the family of graphs we use it
turns out it's not enough to constrain
degrees of the graph but it's it is
enough to constrain cut densities so the
family of graphs we look at is that we
say a graph is typical if for all cuts s
that so here s is a set of vertices for
all and for the actual estimated density
of the graph that the actual edge
density of the graph the number of edges
crossing so I'm going to consider some
cut I'm going to look at the number of
edges that cross the cut and also at the
number of edges inside the cut and those
two should be this those two should be
close to what they what they would be in
expectation under the model with this
parameters so they should it should be
they should be roughly P hat times
through the number of edges leaving the
cut plus the number of edges inside the
cup and it turns out that with some
messing around sorry this T should be
the size of s that should be plus or
minus
and so it turns out that that I mean
it's a sort of standard probabilistic
result that erdos-renyi graph satisfied
this type of constraint and if they
satisfy this type of constraint for all
cuts or all sufficiently large cuts and
as sufficiently for all all cuts up to a
certain size at least then we get
restricted we get a global sensitivity
constraint of the form we need to say
use something like the Laplace mechanism
and so this is really where the work
goes into is arguing that this this
constraint is sort of sufficient to make
things work okay so so that's sort of
the first part we need that the
algorithm behave well on this restricted
class of graphs and then we also need to
be able to take this algorithm and kind
of lift it up to work on all possible
graphs and for that turns out the sort
of extension results that we're in
previous work don't quite fit and we
need to do a little we need something a
little more general and I'm not gonna
even explain why we need the generality
but believe me and essentially what we
need is a way to say if I can take any
algorithm that's differentially private
when restricted to H I can create a new
algorithm that's differentially private
on all possible graphs and behaves
identically to my original algorithm on
H and so that's the the general
extension lemma that we show that I
won't have time to prove to you but that
that's the basic idea of that lemma okay
so in this context it gives us a result
and it gives us this estimation result
and also there's we have some estimate
some evidence that this result can't be
improved any further although it only
kind of only works for constant epsilon
so it's a it's it's not really a full
truth I should mention that that Adam
Steele fun and John almond in recent
work have come up with a polynomial time
version of this algorithm
oh so so I just I went through sort of
what we know about this model and a
little bit about the techniques we can
use in fact that for certain special
cases we get really different behavior
and and so I think it's an interesting
class of models to to play with we also
have this sort of more general extension
lemma that I'll just state very quickly
if I've got any algorithm sorry you can
extend ignore all the other text just
focus on the blue box let's say I've got
an algorithm that's epsilon
differentially private on sub some some
subset of the input space it doesn't
have to this doesn't have to be no
differential privacy just any privacy
with respect to any adjacency notion
then there exists an algorithm defined
on the entire input space which is also
differentially private and it caught it
the parameter gets blown up by factor at
most two and it behaves identically to
the original algorithm when restricted
to H this extension this new album may
not be computable efficiently but it it
exists and it sort of allows us it gives
us a very easy way to get to at least
demonstrate the existence of certain
types of algorithms even though maybe
putting our hands on efficient versions
is remains non-trivial and that's what
some of these papers that I mentioned
earlier actually do in special cases
okay so I'll just wrap up with some
quickly with some open problems there
was this sort of term I did that came
out of the analysis the exponential
mechanism mechanism we don't know if
it's necessary and in fact I suspect you
can at least improve it somewhat using
epsilon Delta differential privacy but
it would require a different algorithm I
don't think it'll follow directly from
the exponential mechanism there is the
mention as I mentioned we have this
lower bound this upper bound for the
address for any man-up model that's
partly matched by lower bound but
effectively it only works for small
values of her larger values of epsilon
meaning constant Epsilon
so getting a lower bound that works for
all epsilon as epsilon goes to 0 remains
open
oops we time efficiency is sort of a big
block here it's true in the non for the
non private analog of these problems the
our understanding of what's possible in
polynomial time is not complete but for
the private analog we know like nothing
so it is still less than what we know
private setting and then there's this
sort of hunch that we have that this
extension lemma can be used to give
statistically useful algorithms and in a
you know range of other settings where
you sort of first design an algorithm
that works on inputs that are typical
for the model and then just wave your
hands and say okay that means I can
extend it to all possible inputs and so
it allows you to just only worry about
the typical ones
more generally four note the class of
note differentially private algorithms
there are lots of things that remain
open so as I mentioned before this or
this question of efficient algorithms
for block models can we even match
what's known non privately not that I
know of continual release of interesting
statistics in the know differentially
private setting is non-trivial so
there's a model called the continual
release bottle where you've got data
coming in over time and you want to
maintain an data structure that allows
you to answer queries about the current
data set so there's a sort of relatively
recent paper of song at all that looks
at this but they do this sort of
assuming a niceness condition on the
graph not enforcing it so that their
algorithm is not private when the
niceness condition is not satisfied and
so in some sense the the hard question
there that remains is whether or not you
can get these types of extension results
but in this continual release setting
there's inference on other natural graph
models there are lots of them and you
know questions about how do we analyze
graphs with attributes so for example we
might want to regret regress income of a
given person on that income average
income of their neighbors or things like
that any any model like that is gonna is
sort of under no type get no privacy
type guarantees is hard hard to work
with and we don't really have good tools
for and simultaneous release of many
different statistics is also a
non-trivial okay okay so I'll just up it
thank you very much
[Applause]
much time as the next speaker system
with few questions and I suspect maybe
all